so i've seen power in its multiplicity
of manifestations and i've certainly
come out convinced for example that
there is nothing more powerful than
than truth in the word that's that's the
fundamental source of
power
any sort of power that you would
actually
dare to want
you know you know what i mean it's like
do you really want power is it
what do you mean by that you want
arbitrary authority over other people
really you want that and it it's
interesting it's interesting that you
say this because i was just watching
re-watching this conversation between
james baldwin and nikki giovanni and
nikki giovanni as a young poetess is
grappling with this
because her the previous generation was
the civil rights generation and she says
you guys are so moral and i'm not i
don't know if i'm interested in morality
get like you she says you know the
saying you know um
gain the whole world but lose your soul
yeah that's saying and she goes give me
the world i want the world and then
baldwin essentially asks her are you
sure you
the the same question that you're
proposing are you sure you want that
kind of power do you know what that kind
of power does
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased to have with me today
ms chloe beltiri
chloe is the developer of a
theory theory of enchantment that she's
using in corporate work and various
other venues
i'll tell you a little bit about her and
then we'll jump into the conversation
after spending a year as a bartley
fellow at the wall street journal chloe
valderri developed the theory of
enchantment an innovative framework for
compassionate anti-racism
that combines social emotional learning
character development and interpersonal
growth as tools for leadership
development in the boardroom and beyond
chloe has trained around the world
including in south africa the
netherlands germany and israel her
clients have included high school and
college students government agencies
business teams
and many more she's lectured in
universities across america including
harvard and georgetown her work has been
covered in the atlantic magazine
psychology today her writings have
appeared in the new york times
and the wall street journal
and chloe spoke a while ago with my
daughter michaela and uh
michaela
enjoyed speaking with her and having her
as a guest and
suggested that i look chloe up and i was
instantly interested in her theoretical
approach and i thought it would give us
an opportunity to talk about
psychological issues and cultural issues
and uh
and away we go so chloe thank you very
much for agreeing to talk to me and the
first question i have for you if you
don't mind is uh why in the world did
you agree to talk to me
this is such a funny question to me um
because i've actually been a big fan of
yours for a long time
i saw you speak in new york city or
actually in long island city
um
a few years ago specifically and i read
your book maps of meaning last year
and i think it's interesting that i
decided to read maps of meaning during
covid it was a very particular
choice and i actually saw your lecture
series on maps of meaning first before
reading it
so
i have been
in conversation with you in a sense for
a very long time now
and i i counted a great honor and a
privilege to be able to talk to you
today
well that should make you radically
unpopular i would say all of that so you
read maps of meaning during covid so how
long did that take you
i think it took me about a month and
then i actually reread my underlined
notes uh before this conversation just
to try to prepare myself
yeah well it's a long read maps of
meaning i put an audio version of it out
and i think that's probably easier for
people because the sentences are so long
that
reading it out loud enabled me to sort
of emphasize some parts and de-emphasize
others and i think that was a good hint
as to the underlying meaning but okay so
well um
so
let's talk about
what you're doing first what is it that
you're doing as far as you're concerned
and
with regards to let's we'll focus on the
anti-racism issue i guess what is it
that you think you're doing
sure so on a very
simple level i have a start-up called
theory of enchantment and we do
anti-racism work and the way we
understand
the
act of anti-racism is psychologically
rooted
and i like to say that we take a page
out of the sages of the civil rights
movement
so dr king james baldwin individuals
like that
our understanding of supremacist ways of
thinking is psychological so the idea is
that supremacist ways of thinking occur
when a human being experiences some kind
of insecurity deep insecurity
within themselves it could be a feeling
of a loss of identity lack of belonging
some kind of self-contempt
for whatever reason
and then they project that feeling onto
the other that looks different from them
in order to feel better about themselves
as a defensive mechanism and so theory
is enchantment yeah sorry i don't want
to go ahead continue with that
so theory of enchantment says
that if that is the case if that is how
this works as human beings then we have
to engage in a series of practices to be
in right relationship with ourselves the
totality of ourselves the complexity of
ourselves so that we become less likely
to overcompensate less likely to project
in the first place so that's essentially
what the theory of enchantment is all
about okay okay so so let let me ask you
a couple of questions about that so i
put together
some some topics for a potential
discussion a while back they're kind of
relevant to our discussion so i thought
i might address some of the more
progressive claims in this discussion
and uh so here are here are the claims
or questions are all white people racist
well what's the answer to that yes and
no i think is the west a white
supremacist society yes and no
is the u.s structurally racist yes and
no is gender fluid yes and no are all
men sexist yes and no and and i believe
the yes and no answers to both of those
and so let's start with this racism
issue so one of the things i kind of
outlined in maps of meaning i think is
that
there are two sources of virulent racism
and one is
universal as far as i can tell looking
at the anthropological literature so one
of the things you see
that's characteristic of human societies
regardless of their size and location is
that there's a strong proclivity for the
members of those societies to regard
those within the society as human this
is particularly true of isis you can
particularly see this in isolated tribes
as human and all other
humans that aren't in the tribal group
as not human
and that's really seems really
deeply rooted and so
you even see it in chimpanzees
our closest biological relative so
the chimps arrange themselves so that
they can function within their own troop
let's say without tearing each other
into pieces except on occasion but
the chimps will send raiding parties of
males around the boundaries essentially
and if they encounter
non-chimp chimps foreigners let's say
even if they were once part of that
troop and had moved
if they outnumber them they'll often
tear them to pieces
and that's a
that was discovered in the 1970s and it
was a major discovery because it showed
how deeply rooted this in-group
out-group differentiation is you know
that it manifests itself even in our
closest animal relative and so if you
say are all white people racist the
answer to that is probably yes
but the corollary is
well that's probably true of all people
correct and so it's it's the problem
with the
proposal that all white people are
racist is that
the fact that a skin color is listed in
the proposition
it's a political move and it
decreases
it it underplays the critical severity
of the problem
yeah right like if it's just white
people that's that's not a big problem
but if it's all people and even our
closest relatives it's like man we've
got something to overcome and then this
is more relevant to what you said i
would say is
given that intrinsic in-group preference
and out-group hatred that could easily
be kindled and that might be there like
deep and even from the beginning are
there ways that we act as individuals
that make that more and less likely and
that has more to do i think with the
psychological development
issue that you were describing so if i'm
bitter and unhappy and resentful and
arrogant and hostile
then that proclivity to derogate out
group members is going to be extremely
attractive to me and so if i get my own
house in order well then i'm less likely
to need a target for my unexamined
malevolence and violence and more likely
to be able to get that intrinsic out
group in group out group differentiation
under some modicum of control
mm-hmm i think that's that's
do you think that seems okay okay so
yeah
i think i think ultimately uh as you
just described the proposal that it is
only white people is actually a
misapprehension of the human condition
and
a misunderstanding of the fact that this
proclivity exists within every single
one of us
and
and you know i take a page from you know
jungian philosophy
or union psychology which argues that a
lot of this enters into the world or the
realm of the shadow so the shadow is
everything we do not like about
ourselves that we project onto the other
and if a person is bitter and resentful
as you say
about all the things that they dislike
about themselves and they haven't worked
on themselves and again they haven't
become in right relationship with
themselves then they're far more likely
to take that and instead of dealing with
themselves project that element onto the
other and then see themselves as
superior to the other and that's where
supremacist ways of thinking come from
and it doesn't actually have to be
racial it can also be in group as you
just described with chimpanzees
um it doesn't have to be strictly racial
or ethnic
um yeah well there's plenty of inter
like there's plenty of conflict between
let's say groups of isolated people who
are of the same race right so yeah
that's so obviously the racial
distinction isn't
isn't the only distinction now we could
have a reasonable discussion between
left and right wing about well here's
some other issues like okay well
given that proclivity for outgroup
derivation and the temptation to
use your violent tendencies on
the other
what
exacerbates that and so one of the
propositions we're wrestling with is
well your own psychological uh lack of
development so if you're a better person
maybe you could get that under control
and that implies you could be a better
or worse person so and then but there's
another issue too that the left
concentrates on pretty constantly which
is and this is a reasonable question is
that
if you see a a society where
one group
on average has more power authority than
the other group
does the temptation posed by that power
and authority
exacerbate the proclivity for racism
and so that would so then you could have
a conversation about whether being white
in america let's say
tempts white people more towards racism
than not but you could have the contrary
conversation too and you could say well
are those who are on the on average say
speaking in groups
more towards the bottom of the
socio-economic distribution because
they're somewhat alienated and
potentially bitter about that and
perhaps for good reason perhaps maybe
they're more tempted towards racism
because things aren't going so well for
them i mean we don't know right but it's
a nice starting place is look this is
this problem that it's hard for us to
wrap our loving arms around the out
group
that's a deep human problem that would
be a lovely place to start yeah well i
think i think there's also
this misconception
that
there's no alienation if you are in
power or one experiences no kind of
alienation or no sense of alienation if
you have quote unquote material power
which i think is a flaw in the argument
uh well it's an interesting weakness i
would say of of socialist arguments in
general is that there's a tremendous
critique of the structure of the
economic system but there's also the
presupposition that if you just had
enough money you'd be doing
things would be much better for you
right they would be somewhat better in
some ways you know we have to be clear
about it to a certain point
yeah yeah well and there's also problems
that money doesn't solve many and
there's so so i would be lovely if
material security
actually produced full security but
it doesn't
so okay okay so so we seem to be
reasonably in alignment about that
um
so
now
practically speaking tell me what what
you're doing and how often you're called
on so they're look the the corporate
world has become rife with
d
well d e i's but dies how i like to
phrase it because i'm not very happy
about it the notion of this catchphrase
diversity inclusivity and and equity
and there are training programs
everywhere to hypothetically increase
people's awareness of those and their
proper behavior and i think the evidence
that those programs work is
extraordinarily weak and there's a fair
bit of evidence that they're actually
counterproductive which i find more
compelling but perhaps not
but
that's the that's the practical
landscape for your activities at the
moment is that correct you're working
essentially as a consultant as well as a
writer
um primarily as a consultant i do some
writing here and there but it's
primarily consulting and um you know
people can basically either enroll in
our online course which we have
or the companies can bring us in to
facilitate workshops that elucidate the
essence of the course or kind of serve
as an appetizer
or a teaser to the course okay so
how are you marketing that how
successful are you why do you think it
works practical questions because
there's obviously a huge market for this
so so why your thing and and how why are
you sure that you're not doing harm just
out of curiosity oh yeah that's a
that's a great question i'll try to
answer the first few questions
um first
so we've actually had no outbound
marketing strategy to date
everything has kind of been organic so
basically i've been interviewed by a
number of different publications and on
a number of different podcasts and those
are the things that drive people to
discover the theory of enchantment
there's been no paid marketing outside
of you know just me showing up on a
podcast to talk about these ideas
um and one of the other drivers
so we have that piece but the other
piece is that a lot of companies are
bringing in these more toxic diversity
and inclusion programs
and they're wreaking havoc in the
workplace they're actually causing
justify justify that claim because
that's pretty radical claim that they're
wreaking havoc those are those are
fighting words let's say so why why do
you believe that what's your evidence
for that so i have been told by folks on
our on demo calls that we have with
potential clients i've been told these
stories about how they bring in
very specific
diversity and inclusion programs where
people are encouraged to segregate
themselves based upon skin color
their lived experiences are assumed
because of their skin color and this
ends up fostering a kind of resentment
on the part of people of all different
races and all different ethnic
backgrounds
and it also ends up fostering a kind of
animosity between peoples of different
backgrounds
and ethnicities and so then these
companies end up looking for a kind of
bomb or kind of
uh remedy to actually fix that problem
and then b-a-l-m-bomb not b-o-m-b
no no
a softer version yes exactly
so but they're looking for some kind of
medicine to fix the situation that they
unwittingly brought in and didn't you
know um were totally oblivious to
okay so that's your typical experience
is that you you're being brought in
after the dei
process has resulted in
uh an unpleasant outcome yes it's either
that or
an individual or group of individuals in
an organization
they're being told that this is the way
to do diversity and inclusion but it's
not sitting well with them it's not they
feel intuitively that something's off it
doesn't speak to them and then they go
out and search for alternative
approaches and then they may come across
theory of enchantment
okay okay okay so i wanted to touch on
something that you mentioned about the
dei process the idea that it's another
one of these propositions that's worthy
of investigation the validity of lived
experience
now you would say well are you an
authority
are you an unquestionable authority
on the nature of your lived experience
and the answer to that is yes and no
it's the same as those other questions
that we discussed because
there's obviously a domain
of subjective experience that you have
unique access to
about which in some sense i can say
nothing
like i if i see that you're in pain if
you tell me you're in pain
i can decide whether i believe that or
not i can decide whether or not that is
a credible claim as far as i'm concerned
but i cannot tell ever
exactly the nature of your experience
and so in some sense you are an expert
an incontrovertible expert on some
aspects of your experience
so that part of the claim is valid the
question is well what's the
universalizing significance of that and
so just because it's true for you
doesn't mean it's true for everyone just
because it's true for you doesn't mean
that it's true for all people who share
any particular element of your immutable
characteristics all of the rest of that
is questionable but a lot of these
claims fly because
well they're true in some sense you
could say well is the u.s structurally
racist
well
it was set up
for the benefit of the people
who set it up fundamentally so yeah in
some sense all cultures are set up to
benefit particularly the people who set
them up and then if there's other people
who come in well you know they have a
harder time of it and is that
structurally racist it's like well
yes and no
but the no is important to assess as
well as the yes right to get an even
handed take on these and also to find
out
how universal this is or how particular
it is to that particular
country like all countries are set up
for the benefit
of
a
relatively homogenous group because
otherwise
it's not a country it everyone if it
isn't homogeneous people aren't playing
the same game right so
the fundamental problem is homogeneity
versus heterogeneity
that's a really deep problem you know
because the problem is well how do we
all get along together and play nice
like children
civilized children in the playground
while simultaneously being quite
different from one another at one
another at all sorts of levels of
analysis it's a huge problem well this
is
the essence of the american project
which is ultimately a conundrum right
because our motto our model is a
pluribus unum
out of many one which is actually an
incredibly difficult thing to accomplish
uh given the human condition and so i
would say that america is different
quite different from any other countries
in the sense that it does hold this up
as it as its motto as it's ideal to
which it aspires to but it also
simultaneously has this very storied
history of
not just having a homogeneous culture
and the typical sense of the word but of
course also in perpetuating you know
systemic cruelty
uh against the other
in this case uh speaking particularly of
african americans so you have these two
warring
trends or
histories
uh within the american system which
makes this question of how to
have these civilized children playing
together
a deeper question and a more difficult
question to solve because america holds
itself up as having this model or having
this ideal rather of out of many one
right right right well it's great ideal
if you can manage it because you get all
the benefits of diversity which means
and so we can talk about diversity why
do you want diversity well
because how do you know you're right
and maybe you're not and someone who
thinks differently than you might have
the key to
to solving the problem and you might
really need that solution so
that's another issue about the diversity
mantra it's like well
yes diversity but then we might want to
specify well
let's really think hard about what we
mean here with diversity
and you know i'll speak psychologically
i think the best way to conceptualize
diversity across human beings is
certainly not racial i think that's
that's an appalling proposition
you can certainly conceptualize
diversity usefully in terms of
personality
and and
we have a pretty good taxonomy of
personality it's not perfect but
you know extroverts have their utility
and introverts have theirs and
highly creative people are can be great
entrepreneurs but they're very easily
scattered and and it's it's burdensome
to be interested in everything let's say
yes um agreeable people are
compassionate and warm but it's easy for
them to get resentful
disagreeable people are competitive and
rather blunt and so they can be hard to
get along with but they'll tell you what
they think so that's useful etc etc and
so
we wouldn't have that
five-dimensional
diversity of human beings if there
weren't
ecological niches for all of those
combinations
so you can see but what do you mean by
that
well sometimes it's sometimes the best
thing to be is an extrovert
so imagine you're like extroverted and
really low in negative emotion
so you're you don't have much fear and
you're out there
well you're probably
a target in an authoritarian state
yes because you just won't shut the hell
up and you're not afraid yeah right so
being an
emotionally stable extrovert that's a
lot of fun there's a lot of positive
emotion but
you're a performer you're out you're not
going to hide and so maybe the the
introverted neurotic who is hiding at
home was much more likely to survive
and so on and so forth and
you can walk through all of the traits
and say well
in this situation that trade is more
appropriate in this situation that trade
is more appropriate
we need the diversity
that that feeds our are and and all of
those intrinsic differences
shape the way we think as well i mean
extroverts think like extroverts and so
on
you see that effect even in political
affiliation at least to some degree so
the idea that diversity is useful
that's a good idea yeah and but then
the manner in which that's
conceptualized there's the rob and now
you said in your work you're taking a
page from the more classical civil
rights leaders yes so those would be
i would say in some sense the
traditionally recognized moral leaders
of the black community is that a
reasonable way of conceptualizing martin
luther king for example i i think that's
partially true yes okay
how is it
what's it missing
well
i would say that the black community
recognizes
both dr king and let's say malcolm x
as
um
if not completely you know virtuous in
every
sense of the word
certainly capturing the fullness of the
human condition
so
i can only really explain this or try to
explain this in psychological terms so i
think martin luther king represented the
the being who had a sense of pathos but
a sense of the fact that
someone was common to the entire human
race
and
believe that it was better to
suffer injustice and commit injustice
because ultimately the person who
commits injustice it becomes corrupted
and suffers an even greater kind of
suffering
and so this is why he advocated for
non-violence and and things of that
nature whereas malcolm x represented the
more aggressive
reactive response to being beaten down
and i think that the black community
would argue that both of these
personalities
are necessary
uh to learn from to learn from that's a
good example of diversity and
personality right there my suspicions
right are that
uh malcolm x was less agreeable
technically speaking than martial king
personality
yeah
yeah
and he can make a coherent political
case from that perspective
absolutely but then he started which is
interesting unfortunately in the end he
was killed but
but before he was killed he actually
began to change so when he went to mecca
and he saw white people
who were muslims who he had no
conception that that was even a thing
he realized that what he was being
taught from the nation of islam was
taught that white people i ironically
was taught that white people were
inferior were an inferior race
um he learned to see his fellow
white brother and sister as in fact the
brothers and or sister and he began to
change which is what got him into
trouble
but still he represents and from a
personality perspective this more
combative response and i think the
proper answer to that is not the
conservative answer
which says we like dr king and we
dislike malcolm x
but actually to be in conversation with
both
and because the danger becomes
if you sort of repress or suppress
the malcolm x type response then that
becomes a shadow
malcolm x represents a natural human
response to someone being beaten down
right
and if you repress it then it becomes a
shadow that you're not looking towards
and you're not acknowledging and that
can become
so unhealthy down the line so toxic down
the line if you don't recognize that
impulse within yourself to respond with
anger or to respond with aggression so i
think that the healthy
uh approach to this is to study both
malcolm x and dr king and say what can
we learn
from both how can we grapple with each
what can we take
from each to in order to synthesize and
integrate a holistic way of being
okay so so back into the back into the
corporate world so
you're called in at least
upon occasion when
the traditional
traditional dei approach has gone wrong
and it isn't surprising to me that it
goes wrong because
what it purports to do is unbelievably
difficult
so
and and
speaking as a clinical psychologist in
relationship to
such problems
there's many more ways to make it worse
than there are to make it better that's
for sure and so
so
what is it that you do that's so
different when you go into a company
under the rubric of the theory of
enchantment
how would you di differentiate yourself
from the from that
dei crowd and
and
we should go back to the issue of
inadvertent
harm producing as well right because how
do you know it's not going to go
terribly wrong
so it's a it's a great question so
our we have three fundamental principles
and again this goes back to
our
animating
main idea which is that anyone can fall
into supremacist ways of thinking it
doesn't matter if you're black why
anyone can fall into it because it's a
part of the human condition and it's
this outgrow of outgrowth of projecting
your own insecurities so
we have three fundamental principles
they are treat people like human beings
not political abstractions
criticize to uplift and empower never to
tear down or destroy
and try to root everything you do in
love and compassion and i can define
what i mean by love a little bit later
but these are our three principles and
so all of the exercises
that we
uh
give people
are essentially in service
of having people be able to embody those
practices and the exercises are not just
dry or wrote or strictly academic
the exercises actually use the arts
as a medium
uh dispel these teachings
so what i mean by that is let's take the
first principle uh treat people like
human beings not political abstractions
we'll take an artist like kendrick lamar
who has this song called dna and where
he says in the song i got power poison
pain and joy inside my dna and you know
kendrick lamar is a pulitzer
prize-winning hip-hop artist so people
know him people are aware of him if
they're not familiar specifically with
his with his
raps they understand who he is in the
zeitgeist so they're familiar with him
somewhat and then we say okay what what
do you think the artist is saying here
about the complexity of what it means to
be a human being when he says i got
power poison pain and joy inside my dna
and you can do that rather than saying
what the answer to that is he asks it we
ask it to our to the participants in our
workshops that's the other thing the
workshops are very participatory it's
not like me lecturing strictly
it's a highly participatory experience
and so what comes out of that is oh i
think the artist is saying that we're
all capable of
good and evil or we're all we all have
these um
we're all capable of experiencing
complex emotions simultaneously that
could be totally contradictory right
this is what it means to be a human
being and so
that naturally leads to the
understanding of the fact that the human
being is in a way inexhaustible
and
that i as a human being because i am
capable
of
doing good and evil
i can then see someone who has made a
mistake
or perceive someone who has made a
mistake let's say who has insulted me
personally for example
i can still see that person with the
fullness of their humanity and i can see
that person as just as that person just
did something harmful i can also see
that person is equally capable of doing
something good even as i'm capable of
those same things
and so what ends up happening through
this process is i am i start to
become in relationship
with my own complexity
and my own inexhaustibility
and then i begin to perceive complexity
in the other
and this is important because if i'm
able that's the anti-stereotype that's
right
then i'm less likely to caricature
the other okay okay okay right right
right okay yeah because the one of the
things that be deviled social psychology
continually there's many things is that
there's all often a failure to
distinguish
bias and prejudice from heuristic
so like we simplify
virtually everything we perceive and
interact with all the time
automatically we can't and it's a good
thing we do because well this
inexhaustibility that you just described
well we have to well that's right it's
exhausting
that's the thing is that if you're
wandering around enraptured by the
inexhaustible complexity of everything
like good luck trying to cross the
street right so we're what we see
technically what we see
mostly is memory
and
the memory is a
it's a heuristic it's a supposition
like i noticed for example i wrote about
this and beyond order
i can really remember the neighborhood i
grew up in
i can i can picture every house
but i can't picture the houses in the
neighborhood i live in now even though
i've lived there 20 years and it's
because
i see house
generic house
i don't see what i saw when i was a kid
which was all the detail
and it's a good thing because well when
i
you see this when you're wandering
around with two-year-olds
they're
completely
enraptured by everything yeah but they
have absolutely no ability to
engage in structured goal-directed
activity it's one of the delightful
things about them but it also means they
have to be cared for non-stop and so we
have this now
what you're proposing is that
if you get people to reflect on their
own complexity including their moral
complexity
so they
they open up a space and think about how
much of themselves is beyond them beyond
their control even
for better or worse
then you can suggest to them that other
people are like that as well and that's
the anti-stereotyping move
yes and and also you can begin to
understand why how people could come to
the conclusions they've come to or how
people can make the decisions they've
made even
while simultaneously disagreeing with
those decisions and so you can disagree
without
um
dehumanizing
or demonizing yeah things can go very
badly wrong in your life and part of the
reason also to appreciate the diverse
complexity of other people is that they
might be able to offer you a solution
when you can't when you really need one
because they think differently than you
do
and so
that i guess meditation on your capacity
for suffering is also
a possible avenue to appreciating the
diversity of other people
i think this is what i think this is
what plato argued and gorgeous but his
retelling of socrates and socrates's
sort of socrates is someone who's trying
to pursue the truth at all costs and
calocles and i don't know if i'm
pronouncing that name correctly but
calocles was the senator who believed
that
that truth was basically defined by
brute strength or power
which should sound familiar because it
is familiar to our our times these days
um but socrates goes into this thing
about pathos about become the suffering
that is common to all human beings and
once you understand the suffering that
is common to all human beings that not
only have you suffered but all human
beings suffer you're able to
become an existential relationship with
other humans and without this
this understanding you will never get
there and this is this has a connection
to the arts
because it is the awareness of suffering
that is present in some so much of
the west in particular as artistic
genius
it's in shakespeare
it's in the african-american blues
tradition it's in dostoyevsky
right it's in steinbeck this
understanding of human suffering
which is ultimately inescapable and this
is also why the the idea that
raising the material standards of
everyone which again is important to a
certain extent
but is ultimately insufficient because
it will not enable us to escape the
ultimate suffering that is a part of the
essence of the reality of existence
when you say so when you say treat
people like human beings not political
abstractions that that's really
you just outlined in some sense what
that means in terms of your practical
approach you're assuming
a simplistic stereotype you're assuming
that
that's more likely to be applied to
people who are different which i think
is true
and that the way through that is
meditation on complexity and suffering
some and the universality of that
something like that
on some level yeah
okay okay it also means correct me if
i'm wrong that your unit of analysis
is the individual fundamentals
yes
okay and that that definitely puts you
in philosophical opposition to the
purveyors of the typical dei approach
because their fundamental level of
analysis i believe it seems to be the
case they pronounce
state that all the time that it's it's
the group in one form or another yes but
i think they're ultimately confused
i don't think it's um
i don't think it's
the deliberate i think i think there's
some confusion happening
yeah well these are complex issues right
and and there are groups of people and
and group identity has a reality
and sometimes it's an important reality
and so
figuring out how to rank these
levels of analysis is no easy business
that's that's at the essence of the
problem in some sense right is
how do you conceptualize the
relationship between the individual and
the group given that both those levels
of analysis exist
yeah well i actually think i think it's
deeper on some level than that and i
have a theory that i want to run by you
i would be very curious to hear your
thoughts
so if you
look at what a lot of diversity and
inclusion consultants say
in their slideshows
they say that they are trying to fight
against quote unquote whiteness
how do they define whiteness they define
whiteness as
um they define it as either or ways of
thinking
no yes they've seen those lists
and these are i'm quoting so you know
either or ways of thinking power
hoarding
analytical forms of thinking linear
forms of thinking etc
yeah it's complete it's completely it's
it's really something to see that it's
incoherent at best but yeah if you look
at if you look at what they say they
want
they say they want a kind of
interdependent
interdependency
or an understanding of our
interdependence as human beings they
want
um
this sort of relational way of being
right and and what they're essentially
arguing for
if i if i read between the lines
correctly
um is an into a kind of alienation
has taken over
culturally their lives and that's
interesting
because these diversity consultants tend
to be more or less left-wing but if you
were to go into right-wing circles
there's this great book by uh
timothy carney called alienated america
which looks into how
many conservative white rural based
americans
voted for trump or why they voted for
trump in the 2016 primary so not in the
general election in the primary when
they had other republicans they could
vote for
and he argues that the reason why the
people who voted for trump voted for him
was because they were suffering from
incredible amounts of alienation
and he traced it back to
an experience of
you could actually see which counties
that voted for let's say trump over mitt
romney these were counties that were
more likely suffering from alcoholism
and deaths of despair and opioid crises
and things of that nature
the disruption of civic institutional
life etc
so i find that this is fascinating
because what this means is
you have on the one hand left-wing
diversity consultants who are confusing
i think they're conflating race with
culture in many ways
and but what they're calling for is an
end to alienation well simultaneously
the way that they're calling for it is
alienating
towards white rural right-wing
conservatives
who for a whole host of reasons but
including that are influenced to vote
for individuals like donald trump which
means there's a common theme which
suggests there's a common theme and the
common theme is alienation
so what is it about alienation
that
creates this
kind of behavior in people regardless of
whether they're on the right or the left
to
um project animosity toward the other
toward the out group what is the role
that alienation plays in this entire
conversation and how do you think what
do you think the alienation what does
alienation mean
what does what's your understanding of
of
that as a phenomenon
yeah
so i think
that the issue is actually
civilizational and not political
um and so there are
you'll find that there are there are
places where i agree with certain
left-wing consultants and there are
places where i will agree with certain
right-wing critics
but i actually think that what's
happening is that fundamentally in
america we've lost a capacity to relate
to one another
we've lost a capacity to be in a
relational way of being with each other
and actually i would argue that that
goes back all the way to certain aspects
of the enlightenment and in particular
descartes
so i would argue so
descartes is considered by many to be
the father of the enlightenment
but he came up with this idea
known as cartesian duality
which argues that there's a distinction
between the mind and the body the cart
was not even convinced that his own body
existed so he his belief was that there
was a distinction between the mind and
the body
and that not only was there a
distinction
but these
entities so to speak were opposed to
each other
and so there's this
incredibly incredible philosophy of
rupture
that was perpetuated throughout the
enlightenment because what that means if
you deny the body
fundamentally
as relevant or as of significance what
you end up denying is the relevance of
human suffering what you end up denying
is the experience
of certain
aspects of reality that are
fundamentally embodied experiences
including things like pain and suffering
ironically there is another
theme or element within western history
which exists in the arts that are part
of western history and western
civilization that do not deny the body
and so i think that this alienation
ultimately is
centuries
in the making and centuries in the
coming and it kind of comes from this
this philosophy which said well there's
also there's there's also a
a universal element to that i would say
um and this is something that the aliens
have highlighted um i would say perhaps
more
accurately than
although existentialist philosophers and
psychologists put their finger on it too
which is this idea of this is a high
dagarian idea of throneness
is sort of the arbit is the
arbitrariness of our existence so you
know you happen to be a black woman and
i happen to be a white man and we didn't
choose that it's just pop here we are
and and there are preconditions to our
existence that we didn't choose
we're also
beneficiaries of and and
and
uh puppets of our of the culture that we
happen to inhabit and
the culture was made by people who
weren't us and who are no longer alive
and
so it's not our own creation and none of
us feel entirely comfortable within it
that's a inescapable part of the human
condition it's it's we're subjugate you
know we're subjugated to
suffering mortality that's the
biological hell in some sense but we're
also subject to the arbitrariness of our
cultural constructions
and
and so and that's a permanent
existential problem and then there would
be
what would you idiosyncratic variants of
it that would be culture specific that
are more
more they're more
uh what would you say
you can use the example of descartes in
the west in that more specific sense
this is a universal problem this idea of
alienation and part of the question is
how do you overcome that and when you
were talking about
sympathy with universal suffering and
appreciation for complexity and
diversity i i i
had
images of crucifixion in my imagination
thought well part of the reason that
that image very strange image to be
worshipped to be so uh to be regarded as
sacred for so long to be so central it
is a image of
the universality of suffering and
inexhaustibility
and so
and it's to see that crucified
possibility in every individual that's
at the center of christian ethos and
but also the capacity to transcend it
right well that's that's built into that
story and it requires a death and a
rebirth right and
you can think of that psychologically as
well as ontologically that that's the
religious question is what does that
mean in terms of the structure of
reality but
we do redeem our crucified diversity and
all the trouble that gets us into by a
sequence of deaths and rebirths that
happens every time we're wrong and we
have to rebuild ourselves
and and
in any narrative of redemption like the
exodus story you see that as well this
escape from tyranny this descent into
chaos and then reconfiguration
and so i thought in maps of meaning i
posited that identification with that
process was redemptive rather than any
of the states right that you are this
thing that's on this journey of
continual self-transcendence and yeah
it's the process itself but the issue is
that
cartesian duality or one of the issues
is that cartesian duality and its
obsession with certainty
and mathematical certainty
has a
problem with the unknown
an existential problem with the unknown
because it's fixated with certainty and
i know that in massive meaning you draw
this
connection to i believe it was milton's
uh depiction of
the adversary of satan and and
and how the evil being is is not someone
who represents the other but someone who
cannot handle the unknown and who is
fixated on certainty
of an absolute sentence and in being
fixated with certainty claims to be god
and i can see that trend within
the cartesian revolution or the
cartesian element of the enlightenment
and being obsessed with certainty you
deny your shadow you deny all the parts
of yourself that you do not like and
then you project that shadow onto the
other and then that causes so many
complications
and that's putting it mildly down the
line
how deep into the woods weeds let's say
do you go in these seminars i mean well
not this deep not as deep as this
conversation but this is what my brain
is often doing in between time
let's go to another
principle
criticize to uplift
empower never to tear down never to
destroy never are strong words but i
understand what you're aiming at because
it's in relationship to the third
principle i believe
see when i when i take talk to students
about
literary criticism let's say
so let's say i'm and this is this is a
problem that needs to be discussed in
some detail in our culture generally
speaking i mean
you can take a look at a figure like
freud or nietzsche let's say and if
you're inclined to
you can find something they said that
you're going to find deeply offensive
and then you can throw them out
completely which means
well it simplifies your life because
then you don't have to read them right
and that does make your life a lot
simpler yeah right but the what you lose
is whatever these people had to say
and so
criticism is separating the wheat from
the chaff
like in its proper sense it's you
criticize something so that you can take
away what's of value and leave behind
what isn't
that's the purp and so that that
proper criticism isn't
destructive
it's redemptive
and why wouldn't you you would criticize
harshly for a variety of reasons you
might want to hurt someone
but even more
simply than that you might just want to
ignore them because we really want to
ignore almost everything and no wonder
like how many things can you deal with
and so if you can write someone off
you can ignore them and perhaps that's
that's more straightforward but
the criticism to uplift
it's part of the therapeutic process you
know i mean partly what you're doing
if you do their individual psychotherapy
with someone is you're
you're trying to help them decide what
to keep and what not to keep
and what to develop and what not to
develop and you can't tell them that
because you actually don't know who they
are yeah you actually don't know and if
you do tell them as a therapist most of
the time
a it won't work you'll just alienate
them right and and b well what if you're
wrong
so you have to ask them it's like and
you have to help them collaborative
empiricism is what the cognitive
behaviorists
describe it as like well
watch your life for a week
see when you're doing better and when
you're doing worse and see what you're
doing when you're doing better and when
you're doing worse let's see if we can
get you doing more of what makes you
better and less of what makes you worse
and that is a
understanding of suffering it's an
appreciation of complexity
there's humility in it because
what
makes you
stable and strong productive
able to overcome your suffering is going
to be exactly the same as what works for
me definitely not and you may not know
what it is because your
complex beyond your own capacity to
understand
that's for sure yeah it's a problem well
that's the inexhaustibility right that
goes right
right so
criticize to practically speaking how do
you teach that to people in your
seminars how how do you go about
well we teach people to do shadow work
or kind of element of shadow work where
we say to people
identify someone that you do not like or
whose behavior you don't like
and but i don't like i don't mean simply
you find it problematic i mean behavior
that triggers your ego in such a way
where you begin to see yourself as
greater than or superior to that person
it's a very specific definition
so identify someone whose behavior i'll
put it more succinctly
triggers your ego
right and then identify
what is it about that behavior that
triggers your ego and then identify how
that behavior shows up in you and what
that does is it enables you to
see the other person's faults
as false but not as
something completely a human
right or foreign to your own capacity to
engage in those faults
which makes your critique of them
more likely to be rooted in
a desire to see them
be better or become their better selves
as opposed to a desire to see them fall
which is still
if you if if the intention is to see
them fall
to harm them you're still in that
inflated ego you're still operating from
that desire to have yourself be superior
to that person or to prove that you are
better than that person um in which case
nothing has really changed in that
exchange
and this is important because if you
criticize
to
tear down and destroy
maya angelou has this wonderful quote
where she says if you tell someone over
and over again they are nothing
they are less than nothing
they will say to you oh you think i am
nothing i will show you where nothing is
and they will become even worse than
what you have accused them of being
and the moral of the story is that a
person cannot develop character
unless they are valued
and when i think of that quote it's not
just you deliberately or explicitly
telling someone vocally you are nothing
it's also you showing them right if a
person of a young person grows up in a
dilapidated home where the parents have
basically all but abandoned the child
the message that is being sent to that
human being is that you are nothing
right and then that child more more
likely than not unless there's some
mentor or something that intervenes in
the process the child will grow up
actually internalizing the message
thinking that they are nothing and they
will act accordingly so our speech
that we use to critique or to correct
others and in indeed ourselves is super
critical and we have to make sure we're
not compounding
or making worse a
situation
um instead of ameliorating it which
ultimately should be our intention
a bunch of ideas were going through my
head while you were describing that um
one of the things that
i found deeply
uh soul troubling on on my tours was
the
hunger that people had for
words of encouragement
i was struck to my core by
how many people
were starving for
words of encouragement and i mean i
really mean that quite literally words
of encouragement
words that would help them be courageous
and and and part of that was the message
i suppose the message that
each of them as individuals had
something unique to offer
that if offered
optimally or
that everyone would benefit from that we
would all be lesser without that
offering and that was important and and
part of the
purpose of moral striving
and
that that was true of everyone and
i i it's still i don't know how much
that affected me to see how
desperate
so many people were for words of that
sort
and and that's part of the alienation
too i think that's rife in our culture
because we also have this
guilt and induced proclivity to
denigrate ourselves as human beings a
cancer on the planet that everything we
do is environmentally harmful that all
our activity is malevolent and ignorant
and i mean we are limited and
often corrupted beings but
you know we've only had ecological
awareness as such in some sense for like
50 years
so
you know how fast can we really learn
this and
we are striving to
live
despite formidable obstacles natural
obstacles and social obstacles and so
it's reasonable to note now and then
that
we don't do so badly for
given the terrible constraints that we
operate within
so
that's i guess part of that appreciation
for the commonality of suffering and
vulnerability
and so okay so your level of analysis is
is is the individual so that's
definitely different that's definitely
different now in terms of rooting
everything you do
in love and compassion
let's let's go to that what do you mean
by that exactly i mean because that can
easily be a cliche right i mean
instantly
yeah
so i'm pulling from
two traditions which i think you'll
appreciate two wisdom traditions uh
one being the christian wisdom tradition
which is rooted in agape love my
understanding of agape love and the
christian tradition
is a kind of love that enables us to
become more human
so
john viveki who i know is one of your
colleagues
who talks about agape love is the kind
of love that a parent
who has unconditional love
directs toward a child
and who in directing that love actually
enables
a being to become more human because
when you're born you're sort of this
blob
right this helpless defenseless blob and
then the love
that a parent actually can direct to you
if it is the ideal agape love actually
enables you to become more human
and that that interestingly enough that
involves this criticism right you know
because well for example
when my son was
my son is more disagreeable than my
daughter so he pushed boundaries quite
hard and it was he's quite disagreeable
in that regard and it was really
interesting to watch him toy with a
boundary like he would just worry that
boundary like mad and
now and then he'd go off to a daycare or
something like that and interact with
other kids and he'd come home
sort of possessed by the spirit of some
misbehaving child he'd encountered that
day and he'd push us with that pattern
of behavior sometimes that would last
for a while and my wife and i would get
together and say look this kid is going
off the rails a little bit here for for
a week he doesn't get away with anything
nothing nothing we just clamp down on
him and every time he deviates a tiny
bit because he was testing testing all
the time we're going to stop him and
every time we did that
his behavior improved he got happier and
he liked us more but what we were trying
to punish him what we were trying to do
is to help him draw those fine
distinctions between what constituted
optimal behavior and sub-optimal
behavior and that was really true in the
domain of play and humor yeah you know
because there's a real fine line
between being
playful and teasy
and funny and annoying and aggressive
and
narcissistic it's a really fine line
and so it's a lovely thing to be able
you need that critical eye to help guide
a child for whom you want the best
to understand those fine distinctions
and that's part of separating the wheat
from the chaff
yeah i think you're i i hadn't made that
connection before actually but you're
right
and
i would say this is important because
agape love is
what dr king said was the ultimate ideal
that the civil rights movement aspired
towards
and wanted to embody this was a part of
the reason why
when people would go out and protest
segregation
in diners saying before they would go
out to protest
they would actually ask themselves am i
harboring a spirit of resentment
am i harboring a spirit of
of rage
or vengefulness and if i am then i'm not
going to go out to protest today because
i'll just end up projecting that onto
the person that i'm protesting
um and they ultimately believe that even
while i am fundamentally and vehemently
disagreeing with this action
that these people are
engaging in this racist action this this
dehumanizing action i want to make sure
that how i comport myself does not
dehumanize you in turn and even more to
the point the way i comport myself is
informed by the spirit of agape love
which means seeing you
as made in the image of the divine even
as you are engaging in this problematic
behavior
which is a very difficult thing
to do
and to practice it like in live when you
know people are calling you racial slurs
or people are threatening you with
lynchings or people are actually in the
process of lynching you it is an
incredibly difficult thing
to practice and embody but this attests
to the strength
of that movement and i think there's so
much more we can learn from that
movement and part of the theory of
enchantment's goal
is to sort of resurrect the spirit of
that movement and bring it back into
public discourse and i think because i
think it has been lost to some extent
well
lost and just difficult and precisely
that you described right i mean wouldn't
it be lovely if we could comport
ourselves in that manner
you know that the goal of your
interactions with someone is to call to
do what you can in all humility to call
forth the best in them at every possible
in every possible way and i do believe
that to some degree you do that with
with truth in speech
with careful attention to to your words
and and you know i've seen some of that
i would say well again
perhaps most particularly in the tours
that i've done
talking to people about
their attempts to improve themselves and
and and their their their desire for
that element of
that's an element of the patriarchy in
some sense right is that
that
that invitation to mold yourself in a
certain way but that should be
encapsulated within this this
overarching
love and what is that love the love is
that so in a more abstract sense the
love is you think that's a hard thing to
manage because we're also angry about
the
limited preconditions of our existence
and our subjugation to tragedy and our
subjugation to tyrannical authority
built into the structure of existence
than to rise above that with your best
self and still to wish for the best to
manifest itself instead of being angry
and wanting revenge for those that
terrible suffering
is that's but you know what what's the
alternative is to make the suffering
worse to make the tyranny worse i mean
you can be attracted to that because you
get so angry and it's like well to hell
with everything and why well because
look what's happened look how injustice
is look at how much suffering there's
been it's like we'll make let's let
everything burn
and especially those who perpetrated but
well
we know where that ends up and hopefully
that isn't where we want to go
so yeah
have you seen the film have you seen the
film wonder woman the first one
that's a good question it's possible
i've forgotten many movies so
why did you bring it up specifically it
is fundamentally about this question
because the villain aries god of war has
this perception of human beings
and says that that it's not worth it
and he poses this
um
he poses he has this proposal that he
offers to wonder woman and he says come
with me and we'll destroy everything
because man has ruined everything and
will rebuild essentially a garden of
eden
and wonder woman's response is
basically
everything you have said
about man is correct
but man is also
so much more
and this is ultimately why she refuses
his proposal and it's a beautiful movie
i highly recommend it even watching is
something i would highly recommend
yeah so that's well this is part of that
yes no answer issue is that all these
claims are true in some sense is that
you know as human beings well we're
capable of just spoiling the planet and
we have to be careful of that but
that it's easy for that to turn into
contempt for humanity and that's just
not the proper that's not an answer
that's going to get us anywhere and i
really like your story about the
meditation that the uh
the protesters
engaged in under martin luther king's
direction i mean i've seen often when
i've counseled people who are in
terrible situations terrible legal
situations for example where
they're just boxed into a corner and
being tortured to death for absolutely
unjust reasons
one of the things we always did while
strategizing was to
help
maintain the attitude
that
nothing should be
uh voluntarily made worse and i'll tell
you like if you're in a difficult
circumstance a really difficult
circumstance where everything is at
stake
and you drift into resentment and start
making your own moral errors
the only potential pathway to your way
through might have been compromised
mm-hmm so
because you just can't afford it
yeah well you're going to cause more
trouble and like what makes you think
you can take more trouble under these
circumstances maybe there's some thin
line that you can walk that will get you
out of the situation reasonably intact
but if you fall prey to dark and
unexamined motivations that may be
the end for you that in all in all
important ways
so
and this is this is important because
there are so part of my critique of the
progressive take on diversity and
inclusion or
an aspect of it at least is this idea
that people in power
material power people who have material
power
somehow have it all
as if
people in the who have material power
are incapable of falling into that very
same spirit of resentment and making
their lives absolutely worse although on
the surface it may look like
uh they are
oppressive and of course they are in in
a certain way but it's interesting so
james baldwin was in a debate
uh
in
the 60s i believe maybe it was the 50s
i'm not sure but he was in a debate in
the uk and he was debating a
conservative actually
william f buckley
and
he
gives this these opening remarks about
the specter of racism in the south
and he talks about the alabama sheriff
the racist alabama sheriff
who takes his baton and beats a young
black woman and this is a very
controversial statement but if you
understand anything about pathos or
anything that we've been talking about
you understand what he's saying
he says on some level i have to assume
that this
racist sheriff is a man
and presumably presumably he loves
his wife and he loves his children and
he loves to get drunk now and then but
yet he doesn't know what drives him to
pick up the baton and hit this other
human being and beat this other human
being
in some ways what has happened to the
human the other person that he beats
is bad but what has happened to him is
in some ways far worse
and this is not about right this is not
about material access to power this is
about the existential
implication
of what happens when a person becomes
um
sort of corrupted by power right and
falls into
absolute an absolute kind of hell and
perpetuates hell
right that is in and of itself a kind of
nightmarish thing
to contemplate
one of the things i learned in part from
jung but also from many of the other
people i read was don't be so sure you
know where true power lies yeah
i mean and so for me like true power
lies in beauty true power lies in truth
and i mean that most practically i've
met people at all walks of life i've had
a very diverse range of encounters with
people partly because of my travels and
partly because of my work as a clinical
psychologist i've worked with people at
every level of the ability spectrum
from people who
really struggled to fold a piece of
paper well enough to put inside an
envelope to people who've generated
world shaping technologies and it's
so i've seen power in its multiplicity
of manifestations and i've certainly
come out convinced for example that
there is nothing more powerful than
than truth in the word that's that's the
fundamental source of
power
any sort of power that you would
actually
dare to want
you know you know what i mean it's like
do you really want power is it just what
do you mean by that you want arbitrary
authority over other people really you
want that and it it's interesting it's
interesting that you say this because i
was just watching re-watching this
conversation between james baldwin and
nikki giovanni and nikki giovanni as a
young poetess is grappling with this
because her the previous generation was
the civil rights generation and she says
you guys are so moral and i'm not i
don't know if i'm interested in morality
get like you she says you know the
saying you know um gain the whole world
but lose your soul
yeah that's saying and she goes give me
the world i want the world and then
baldwin essentially asks her are you
sure you
the the same question that you're
proposing are you sure you want that
kind of power do you know what that kind
of power does
to a person how it corrupts
people and how it causes people to make
these
very violent brutal cruel decisions are
you sure you want that kind of power and
it's a really beautiful exchange so it
definitely resonates with me what you're
saying
yeah well
all right so let's
i would like to to ask you
some more cultural questions sure okay
it's to comment on some some broader
cultural
figures you talk about rob and d'angelo
tell me about robin deangelo and and and
those that set of ideas if you don't
mind tell me what you think
i really don't think that often about
robin d'angelo
i know she wrote a book called white
fragility which was published last year
and was all the rave
i found it
incoherent
um but i learned why what what was in co
and maybe this isn't productive like i
don't want to i don't want to push you
into commenting on robin downs maybe
that's just not a reasonable place for
this car i'm interested in your take on
some of the figures who are
yeah in some sense leading the culture
that's producing the dei seminars and
all of that and
so that's where what i'm trying to
explore so my issue with robin d'angelo
is my issue with many of the
[Music]
um
many of the figures who are touted or
who are poor promoted in this space
which is they seem to define the black
experience
exclusively in terms of degradation
and
peril
as opposed to
a capacity to understand actually the
incredible richness of
the black experience
certainly has
this on the one hand
uh experience with cruelty and brutality
but also has this incredible
tradition especially as manifested in
the arts okay so let me ask i want to
segue into something that i'm pulling
out of the atlantic article that was
written about you okay sir this will be
a more productive
way of approaching this i think so
abram candy is is quoted here
before and after the civil war before
and after civil rights before and after
the first black presidency the white
consciousness duels the white body
defines the american body the white body
segregates the black body from the
american body the white body instructs
the black body to assimilate into the
american body the white body instructs
the black uh sorry the white body
rejects the black body assimilating into
the american body and history and
consciousness duel anew the black body
in turn experiences the same duel the
black body is instructed to become the
american body the american body is the
white body it's like i read that and i
thought
ah
no
no no not exactly like i get it i get it
so what it is
my take was way worse than that response
okay well
i want to hear it right away well here's
where i think the mistake is being made
and it's a fundamental mistake it's like
it isn't obvious to me as a canadian say
looking at the united states that a huge
chunk of the american body hasn't been
like
remarkably defined by black culture
it's unbelievable i mean
and it is especially in the arts and and
yeah and that's that's that's a
statement of admiration not of
denigration it's like
there there isn't anything in some sense
that's more more closely aligned than
the com
in the combination of beauty and truth
than the arts and to look at black
domination in some sense or at least
massive influence
in an endless array of cultural spheres
especially musically and god where would
life be without music
and be unbearable without music and so
this black genius and you see it
manifest itself in ways that just compel
imitation
yeah they compel this tremendous
imitation which is real admiration right
that's real admiration is and it's
continually imitated to think of the
effect of black music on
well
just every genre you can think of
virtually and so what what is that sort
of state what's part of that statement
is well look
cultures are set up to benefit
the dominant group and it has to be that
way to some degree because there is this
problem of uniting the many into one
right it's a big problem but to to make
a blanket statement like that it's like
it it isn't obvious to me that the
american body is so pure white it's not
obvious to me at all
well well part of my issue with ibrahim
ghindi is not simply his
mischaracterization
of
the impact that white people have had on
our country but
by extension his mischaracterization of
the impact that black people have had on
this country
one of my favorite authors is albert
murray he wrote an incredible book which
is actually a collection of his writings
um called the omni-americans and the
subtitle is alternatives to the folklore
of white supremacy and there's an
incredible
parallel between what he writes about
the african-american ethos what he calls
the african-american idiom as expressed
in music and jungian's ideas about the
hero's journey he argues that the
idiomatic expression as musically
expressed and things like
the blues and jazz and swing and hip-hop
this is not simply a literal
thing it is a metaphorical expression of
this capacity to play
with whatever life
gives you
including the negative potential and
positive potential the capacity to play
is what affords a kind of elegance that
emerges out of the base muck of life
right and he calls it impromptu heroism
culture right which sounds very similar
to the hero's journey and that capacity
to play is precisely what has been
admired
from
the wider american culture and which has
allowed black american culture to
pervade
american culture and turn it into this
composite and so the problem is much
more embodied composite too so it is in
some sense um
the cart yeah you bet you bet it's it
it's a medication
it's and it works so well because it's
not pro it's not exactly
propositionalized it gets underneath the
propositions so
you have said in maps of meaning that it
is action right that presupposes
ideas and john verveiki has said that
you know we've been caught up part of
the problem that we're dealing with in
the west is this this false
understanding of meaning as derived from
propositions when it is in fact
participatory ways of knowing that give
rise to propositions in the first place
and so african-american culture black
culture is a very embodied participatory
relational
experience especially as expressed in
the arts and this is what is admired in
the wider american zeitgeist and so
ibrahim kindy
has been
i would say that he he has been filled
with far too much despair
uh and he is actually underestimating
the power of black culture in his book
all throughout his book among other
things but that is
um incredible because you know he comes
with this desire to
end racial injustice but
doesn't see that he has actually a blind
spot which
mischaracterizes
america the american experience and
fundamentally
uh depicts the black experience
exclusively as degradation which is
precisely what white supremacists do and
that's the irony in all of this and
that's a tragedy in all of this
why term at the theory of enchantment
you're careful with your words you
obviously thought about that for a long
time and yes so
so yeah i mean this it's interesting
because i feel like
the term enchantment came to me
almost in passing i was trying to figure
out how to
and we don't have to get into the
details of this i'm happy to get into it
if you'd like but i was trying to
teach people
or figure out a framework that could
teach people how to love each other in
the agopic sense of the word
and then i began to ask myself what are
people already in love with
and so i ventured into pop culture
because pop culture shows us what people
are already in love with and
i started to study
aspects of our popular culture which
included things like disney films and
nike
and
beyonce and all these brands that have
quasi-religious
actually not quasi religious-like
devotion
from their fans and i was just
like why what what is happening
there that's so interesting because it
means that you you this is one of the
problems i have with the rationalist
atheist types it's a major problem it's
like
forget about the ontological claims of
religion and
that that isn't the issue in some sense
as far as i'm concerned and this touches
on your discussion of descartes it's
like
people obviously obviously have the
capacity for religious experience we
have the capacity for awe and you could
say well aw isn't a religious experience
well that's a matter of definition and
we could play that game but but if it
the awe is deep enough
and it's a definitional issue is is
for all intents and purposes deep aw is
religious or or we need another word
that means the same as religious if
we're going to talk about it and you
participate that participate in that in
dance and in music and in these popular
stories which is why i've been so
interested in taking apart disney films
for example and they're very expensive
productions they're very labor-intensive
the people of genius work on them they
have huge cultural impact and and
they're extraordinarily popular it's
like what's going on here
exactly and so it's definitely worth an
analysis
and
and i think you're wise to to start with
well what is it that people are valuing
and and why
it's an empirical observation in some
sense this is where they're deriving
meaning and value
and the deep study of that is a
religious study
and well there's just no escaping that
so okay
so you're looking at pop culture and
i'm looking at pop culture and i'm
studying disney and beyonce and apple
and nike and all these brands
and i'm looking for a common theme to
see if there's a common pattern across
all of these
and the common pattern i'm seeing is
that all these brands are creating
content where their audience sees
themselves they're
they're imperfect selves
and their potential
reflected in the content which is why
they gravitate toward it
and so i'm seeing you know these disney
films that are motifs for the human
condition where this imperfect flawed
would-be hero has to go through a series
of ups and downs and ups and downs and
ups and downs to discover their
potential self and emerge the hero i'm
seeing
you know almost every nike ad being this
this narrative for this um you know sort
of
uh junior varsity athlete trying to
become better and better and better at
her craft and then emerge
in a spirit of excellence i'm seeing
beyonce say things like who run the
world girls and women gravitating
towards that because they see their
potential reflected in those lyrics
and
it's a universal it's a universal ideal
that compels us to imitate and that's
what attracts our attention and that
pattern to identify that pattern is to
look for what is truly religious because
the pattern that underlies all of the
pattern that underlies everything that
compels us
is the religious pattern and it's the
religious instinct that orients us
towards that and that is not an
ontological claim about the structure of
reality i'm not saying anything about
god this is this is a different kind of
conversation right now that might point
to god and in some sense it most
definitely does but that isn't the same
as the discussion about whether god
exists right as a
from a propositional perspective which
would be the wrong question anyway i
would argue but um
but yeah so i i was
seeing all of this emerge from the
research that i was conducting and then
at the time i also read a book called
enchantment
which was written by guy kawasaki the
former marketing director of apple
and he defined enchantment as a process
by which you delight someone where a
person sort of starts to open up
to life like it's an enticement
enticement
an invitation
an invitation an attraction so to speak
and
um he
he said that this can be present in a
human being and a product and an idea
and he also said that steve jobs
used this
idea to design apple products to sort of
figure out this the aesthetic of what
apple products should look like and
meanwhile you know the idea of
enchantment correlates very closely with
disney because disney is
that takes place in these enchanted
forests and these magical kingdoms and
there's this underlying concept of
enchantment
and so i just decided
that enchantment seemed like the proper
word to define this or to describe this
phenomenon by which we
start to open up to the complexity of
ourselves and thus
to others and can and which can give us
a sense of a relational way of being as
opposed to
a consuming way of being right eric from
the philosopher
wrote a number of of essays on the
difference between having and being and
how he talked about how in the west in
particular we have become caught up in
this need to consume where we define our
identity according to how much we
possess
according to how much we have
as opposed to our capacity to become
wise to be right not to have to be to be
wise to be
that should also be viewed with a
tremendous amount of sympathy because it
wasn't that long ago when we were all
like struggling to feed hand to mouth in
the face of terrible privation and
starvation it's very well
yes yes so so that's another place to
have some sympathy for hyper-consuming
human beings it's like oh look we we
have enough oh well that's never
happened before ever so now we don't
really know what to do with this
yeah i hadn't thought of that but that's
very that's very well said um and it's
not like we don't need you know we have
we do have to have things right to
survive we have to have food and water
and shelter
but
we've fallen into what john vervicky
calls this modal confusion
where we say i want to
be mature
so i need to have as many carbs as
possible right so we're confusing the
having mode with the being mode so
enchantment the the objective of
enchantment of the theory of enchantment
is to bring people back to this
relational way of being
and to be in balance with the complexity
of themselves which includes the having
modes right which includes our shadows
which includes our aggression which
includes our um angst and anxiety
and our melancholy it's not to the end
of suppressing any of those
sort of more negative more darker
emotions but to be in balance with all
of them which is what young said was the
ultimate ideal or the ultimate objective
of doing shadow work in the first place
so what kind of what's happening when
you're giving your seminars as far as
you can tell like what do people
experience and what kind of feedback are
you getting from
from from
the people you're working within in the
corporate world
um
yeah we get really good feedback so we
give surveys um out after we do a
workshop to
to get people to gauge people's
reactions
and people actually describe it as
transformative they use that word in
particular to define the experience and
um they say that they've never seen
or approached diversity and inclusion in
this way this was a new
a new thing for them to approach
diversity and inclusion
some people said that it made them
see the wonder of every human being
which is really what the idea of
enchantment is is getting at
some people actually
a rare few but there are some people
who
are clearly coming from the more ibram
kindy-esque
view
and who say
that this had this
this is basically insufficient
at best
or
or very much problematic
and i it's so interesting for me because
i i had to work on myself because
sometimes i would be in a workshop where
where someone was clearly
from that mode of thinking and they
would say something and it would trigger
my ego it wasn't that i it wasn't only
that i had a problem with what they were
saying is that it would trigger my ego
and i would steal myself
better than them or superior to them and
then i would have to calm myself down
and tell myself well you know chloe
you've also caricatured people in the
past and you've also stereotyped people
in the past so this action that this
person is engaging in is not something
that's foreign
so you can
engage this person in that spirit of
critique the very second principle that
you are espousing without separating
this person from what it fundamentally
means to be human and that's the cool
thing about theory of enchantment is
that it becomes
a self-fulfilling thing if i want to
facilitate
a workshop
or any any teaching on theory of
enchantment i actually have to practice
it and i have to stop myself
when i am being caught up in these
impulses overcompensated for my own
insecurities and anxieties
um so that's but overall the response
has been very very good and very very
supportive
and so what sort of criticism have you
attracted
on the ideological front and has this
been troublesome for you personally and
how have you dealt with that and how
much impact do you think your
work is having in the broader cultural
arena
can you tell
yeah i don't i think you know we're only
a two-year-old organization so very much
startup life
and um
but the impact that we've had in in the
individuals that have taken either our
online course or have sat through our
workshops
it's pretty profound like many of the
testimonials that people write to us are
pretty
long
and offered of people's own accord
so that's really a testament but i would
say on the ideological front it goes
back to that
so it's interesting because there's one
response i don't know if you've heard of
this but the response is
it is not
it is not incumbent upon black people
right to teach white people oh yes
that's unpaid emotional labor or
something like that right yeah yeah and
to take a page from your book i would
say that the proper response to that is
yes and no
right right right exactly
and
but but my
initial response was one of contempt to
be totally honest because
i'm of the opinion
that
dr king
was someone who
was a kind of zen-like
figure
who worked on himself deeply
and understood the human condition in a
very profound way
and anyone who is in that
who finds themselves in that space
i would argue has i would even go so far
argue has an obligation
um to
show people the way so to speak because
you can only come to the conclusion that
like it's not incumbent upon black
people to do that emotional labor if you
are still thinking that
people who are racists in
positions of power are somehow not
suffering
you can only come to that conclusion if
you see them in this caricatured sense
of
ironically
all powerful omnipotent
right and this is where that's right
that's right that's exactly right and
then you you diminish you diminish any
real sense of
of what you have that is grounded in
genuine power and i mean right people
have access to the truth
people have access to the truth in some
sense independent of their socioeconomic
standing and you you talked about the
heroic venture
of of of play
in relationship to musical culture let's
say it's like well here we are alienated
from in in some sense as a class what
can we do that's still
a triumph it's like well there's music
and what is music exactly if it isn't a
call to a higher form of being and and
something that
we don't want to trivialize this it's
like
this is a major accomplishment this is a
major accomplishment no it is it is
incredible i i practice music and i
practice dance as a kind of form of
spiritual practice so you can see this
poster of aretha franklin behind me
and in front of me there's a massive
poster of alvin ailey who was an
incredible dancer an incredible
choreographer so i believe that music
and dance are
in the literal sense spiritual practices
that can actually help us they're also
immune to rational criticism yes which
is so cool it's like
shut up i'm listening to the music yeah
life is meaningless shut up i'm
listening to the music and this is this
is why i say that the ultimate like if
you are politically speaking
if your move is to caricature people you
will always clash with the arts because
the task of the arts is to give
expression to the full range of the
human condition if you take an acting
class and you're playing a character
that is the villain
if you the professor will tell you
never actually see your character as
quote unquote the villain you actually
have to inhabit that person's mind and
understand where that person is coming
from which defies all caricature right
which defies stereotype so the purpose
of the arts
is to give expression to that whereas
today in our
political culture it is popular to
reduce people to stereotype and reduce
people to caricature which is why i
think pop culture in particular or
broadly speaking and the arts in general
can rival that and give that a run for
its money
that's a good place to stop i think
i really enjoyed talking to you
like
it's
it's always
everything you said to me indicated that
you've done a lot of thinking
it's very interesting to see
and so
i pushed you on a lot of topics and you
had more and more to give the harder i
pushed so that was extremely interesting
and i
hope that you can keep yourself
oriented in the spirit of your
undertaking and
wish you well and
and
success in what you're attempting and
you're how old are you
i'm 28.
you've got a long way for someone who's
28 so it could be really interesting to
see what happens to you
yes over the years
so
thanks a lot for talking with me and uh
more power to you as far as i'm
concerned
thank you i and i and i just i just want
to say i i have been a huge fan for a
very long time and i want to encourage
you to continue
with what you're doing because
it has been an incredible respite to
many of us in these trying times so i
want to
to encourage you to go as they say in
the bible from strength to strength